you've never seen me like this before
i think i can't control anything
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today i'm joined
by teenage hitmaker shawn mendes
he's a platinum selling singer
songwriter with a pair of number one
albums under his belt
and good news for sean mendes fans
there's more new music on the way but
first the wings of death sean welcome to
the show thank you for having me man
i know that you once pranked your little
cousin with a hot sauce cookie uh-huh
but now that you're on the receipt yeah
how are you with hot food
um i should be okay i don't want to come
in here confident and and mess up on the
third wing
but i think i can make it to the end my
friends won't let me live it down if i
don't
they're so excited um and their main
thing was like dude i don't care what
happens you have to make it to the very
end so
promise i got you guys
[Music]
these look really good by the way
it's good it tastes like regular wing
[Music]
i shouldn't eat the whole thing should i
or should i it's up to you no
i'm gonna eat it there you go sean so i
want to start by talking about the sean
mendes blueprint because in just a few
short years you went from learning
guitar on youtube
to playing a sold out arena tour with
taylor swift in the beginning
how much of your free time were you
spending on youtube and what were you
watching
that's all i was doing actually i was i
was basically just like obsessed with
youtube covers like people covering you
know whatever
top pop songs were at the time it wasn't
until ed released those acoustic videos
of him
and the green sweater and he's like
singing the a team and stuff
i saw that and ever since then it was
six seven hours a day just learning
videos like people playing online and
just copying them and that's how it
started how were you
treated by other kids during the come up
does having a big
popular online following translate to
being popular in high school or not so
much
not at all actually for the first couple
years it was pretty bad in school going
into ninth grade is the scariest thing
in the world
but i was going in singing you know pop
songs
and it was like walking through the
halls and like 12th graders they asked
me to sing for them and stuff
which it was cool you know i i knew what
my outcome was so and
what i wanted it to be at least so i was
just kind of pushing through it who's
laughing now
exactly right those same guys just
hitting me up being like yo what's up
man how you been
good actually he's still singing
[Music]
who's the wingmaker who did these dom
that was all you little wave you're
really good at making wings eh you hate
making them at home now
you will never make wings at home
so know that you're a product of
pickering canada it's a city just north
east of toronto but over the last couple
years you've been very much a citizen of
the globe
they say that canadians are the most
polite people on earth is that that's
how you feed them hot wings
yeah is that true um yes
probably true but it's annoying like
we're like way too polite
like i caught myself driving down the
highway and some guy cut me off and i
went to honk at him and then i stopped
myself from honking
i was like that is that really how we
are in canada like we actually just
don't honk
it gets really annoying so it's a good
and a bad thing what's one place in
canada that everyone should visit before
they die
you gotta go to vancouver victoria
island and and
just like you can like rent a boat for
like 45 bucks if you have a license
and just go on the water and it's it's
stunning dude you can't really see
anywhere like that
who's the better hockey player you're
bieber uh definitely bieber
i played for a couple years and i've
seen videos of him playing on the ice
and i would not get on the ice with him
he would skate
circles around me for sure
[Music]
i was really worried i came in already
my face was already red
i already felt like i ate 10 wings
what's guitar store etiquette to you
like in other words
how loud and for how long can i riff
sweet child of mine before i have to buy
something i really
i really don't i hate people who do that
stuff dude do not go play sweet child of
mine for like 30 minutes
otherwise everyone in the store is gonna
hate you you just see the staff walking
around like they want to kill themselves
it's the worst vibe
and then what about two because
sometimes you'll go into a guitar store
and even a guy like you might run into a
curmudgeonly
employee who you have to like prove your
credit to do you ever find yourself in
that situation oh they just don't even
want to mess with you you're like hey
can i
like the expensive guitar over there
that's locked up can i get that down
and they look at you like you can't pay
for that
what's the holy grail what's the one
that's most special to you i got a
guitar from john mayer
i think it was like about a year ago and
i was and i just kind of
was getting to know him texting about
guitars asking kind of like what
electric i should start playing and he's
like what hotel you're staying at i said
wherever i was staying
i almost just told people where i stayed
um
and then i kind of got back to the hotel
that night and i went to the front desk
and said hey is something here for me
and that there was a john mayer like
sign signature
strat there for me and it was like the
coolest thing ever i freaked out
the hot one sauce you've got wing eating
down eh
i'm actually probably a little
disgusting with it because i have to
talk
so i feel like i have to eat it get it
in chew it up
swallow it down and then get the
question out i actually thought about
this and i was like man i hope i don't
look like a savage in the wings but i
was like i think there's only one way to
eat them
like a savage yeah so asking a
singer-songwriter to break down their
hits that would be like asking da vinci
do you explain the mona lisa so don't
worry i'm not gonna ask you it's not
like the
special sauce but i know that there is
something
that takes just an album cut and turns
it into a stadium
anthem it's funny as a songwriter you
always take your song and then you go
play it for the best producer or the
best songwriter
and ask for their opinion and then it's
usually like you know whether it's good
they'll be like oh that's pretty good
but you never are getting like dude
that's
that's the best song i've ever heard
because they're also making like really
awesome songs like the best thing i
could probably do is just like
pull a random person off the street and
be like hey do you like this or not
well that's what i was wondering you
know like how do you know like what
sorts of things are you looking
for when you're gauging the likelihood
that
50 000 people are gonna sing this song
back to you someday
there's an immediateness to hits i think
like the second you hear the first
guitar thing i'm this is starting to
feel a little hot
the second you hear the first guitar
thing or like the second you hear the
first uh
verse line or something you kind of see
it in the room
i woke up in the morning with that
in my head and i was like this is a
thing like i know something about this
there's something about this and the
second i had this like little
like ukulele type guitar i played it in
the room and the second i heard it i was
like okay
this is it like i could feel it with
that one the next day went to the studio
and boom
the hammer jang
[Music]
didn't you tell me these were like kind
of safe they sounded really spicy man
it messes with your mind a little bit
you never have to think this hard when
you're eating spicy wings
all right sean so we have a recurring
segment on our show called explain that
gram where we do a deep dive on our
guests instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more context
so i'll bust out the laptop i'll show
you the picture and then you just tell
me the bigger story does that sound good
oh it's starting to get really spicy now
it's going down it took us so long to
figure out a time to do this interview
because i had i had to not sing the next
day i couldn't sing after this
or even i could barely talk after this
you could sean i couldn't
thank you all right first things first
it's a shawn mendes taylor swift yeah
birthday two-parter one looks like it's
her birthday the other one looks like
it's your birthday
yeah they're both birthdays the first
time i ever played madison square garden
there was a big radio show there and
taylor was playing the show
and she invited me to her birthday party
crazy crazy crazy
night i think i was like maybe 16 there
i walked in
and got in the elevator with justin
timberlake ryan said her
and then i walked upstairs and the first
two people i saw were jay-z and beyonce
and i was like
wow this is what it's like to be at a
taylor swift birthday party she brought
me on stage
on my 17th birthday i looked so weird i
was so uncomfortable on stage without a
guitar i just like weirdly held myself
while she had like 70 000 people saying
me happy birthday
when i was on tour with her right when
stitches was kind of happening so i was
on tour with the biggest artist in the
world
and then my song was taking off at the
same time and it was kind of just like
the stars of line i always say like it
was like the stars were aligning for
for me at that time they are all the
time it feels like
fellow canadian icon drizzy yeah that
was the best night of my life that was
the night of the amas i met him at the
awards show
and then i was not expecting from drake
at all i've never i had no idea he goes
yo i love that video with you and your
boys on the str
on the street and i'm like something big
like if you know that that's like my
second song i ever released of all time
the most wack video of me like with like
llamas on the street
it was it was really funny that he
brought that up later he had like a
party i went and saw him at the party
and it was just really cool he like was
he was just really really sweet knew a
bunch about me
and then we took a photo and that to
this day is the coolest photo of me on
the internet
dude this is getting bad
[Music]
it's bad to know that they just get
worse from here
it's psychological yeah i could yeah i
think something's happening that has
nothing to do with the hot sauce
so every big star has their own
protection task force
you know be it the rihanna navy or team
drizzy
or the mendez army you'll have these
fans that'll take
up for you for their figurehead but then
the funny part of it is
you don't really have much control over
them but have you ever tried
to use the mendez army to do your
bidding definitely
especially when there's like voting
award shows they're an actual army they
just go
home they go hard dude and if they can
vote like unlimited amount of times
they can vote unlimited amount of times
like each person
they can they really get the votes up
there in the millions so yeah
so we've been trying to unite our fans
we've been trying to galvanize them
under the spice lords banner
yeah but it hasn't gained much traction
i don't think he's gonna have it's it's
kids like me
because we can't force it on him is that
the thing is it like a nickname it just
has to happen
yeah you i didn't come up with mendez
army that was all dead the mendez army
came up with mechanisms exactly
i don't think you can come up with it
really when you think back on all the
strange things that fans have done to
try to get your attention is there a
story that stands out
um i had a delivery to my house one day
from norway and in the in the box was
like these fans
and this big book about how they like
looked at vines and youtube videos to
figure out the number of the house
across the street from mine the stop
sign where the
the fire hydrant was to kind of like
triangulate which house was mine
and it was cute because they they had no
idea what they were doing but the fact
that they were able to figure out that
really kind of stressed me out i had
like a fan show up on my door in like
the middle of the winter
and she had like basically like a crop
top on and shorts in the middle of the
winter
and she goes i i don't know what
happened i just am lost
and like you're lost eh you just yeah
like i don't know where i
am like i'm like oh i see she knew i was
i just need someone to drive me to
starbucks i'm like oh
you're really good okay i'll drive you
to starbucks and i was like she had me
i there was no way getting out of it you
drove her i drove her she was really
smart i gotta give it to her
one girl um sorry
she came in and she like it's starting
to get really bad actually
uh she came in and um she would just
like
expect burst into tears like insane
crying
at one time she grabbed onto my legs and
like was great
my guard had security guard had to like
kind of pull her off of me and she was
like fully grabbing onto my whole body
we had to get a picture of her and
beware of her
every time i see her my heart drops a
little now
i wonder though if like the more hot
sauce you start to eat if it starts to
be less hot like if i ate that up right
off the bat would it be worse
we did have one guest start at 10 and he
would tell you that it was a mistake in
a bad mood yeah
i just don't feel good right now right
like overall like
it's more than just the heat i just like
i feel like i'm going to throw up on
this table
welcome to my yeah so we've touched on
it a little bit but you had this
breakneck
rise to fame doing bedroom covers to all
of a sudden having a number one album
what happens between the time that
you're signed
and when you go out to play a stadium of
20 000 people is there some sort of boot
camp or do they just push you on stage
and say good luck
it's kind of just get on stage just like
throw me in the pool and learn to swim
type of thing you know
the one thing i learned especially
meeting people like ed and taylor
and justin timberlake was that their
incredible superstars and
and just incredible are real people
and like one conversation with them
they'll tell you that they feel the same
way
this is kind of a little bit brutally
honest that's why there's a lot of
really
amazing musicians and artists who aren't
as successful as they should be
because it's much more than just the
music sometimes you know being able to
handle the wings and the shows and the
interviews and the tv and
flying to 10 cities in like a month is
like
is a lot and so if you can't handle that
you're not going to be able to break
through
and then when you take on a load like
that you know you start scaling out a
team and i'm sure at that time you have
a stylist that says
wear this and a social media manager
that's like tweet this and a
choreographer that's like move like this
when that all first started happening
what are some things that you found
yourself pushing back on i only wore
flannels and i only wore black van shoes
and
khakis which looking back on just looks
not good at all maybe the stylist was
right she was right she was very right
because the first day i put on a leather
jacket was like the best day ever
is it hard to censor yourself from
swearing on stage
uh yeah i swear a lot in person even in
interviews
sorry man whoa um
i swear yeah so i swear a lot in like
real life but in interviews i think
there's something that's
kind of trading my mind to just like
when the swear word comes change it well
sean i'd say
let it fly on here i got you you're
going for it eh
you don't feel it at all you seem fine
well i have to put up
a front i think to make me feel better
to comfort you yeah you do
the father-son type situation what's
going on right here
all right so this one is the bomb beyond
insanity
[Music]
shit's gonna get real right now
this looks like it's not even supposed
to be eaten it's just for hurting people
try and eat a good amount of the wing
for the people for people
for other people
that's [ __ ] up that's bad now you tell
me i can swear
you can't i guess where i i miss the
hots i don't know what's going on now
people don't actually eat this for like
flavor though man
product of kansas merchant
what's wrong with you people
[Music]
so know that you're a harry potter
obsessive that's horrible
and not above binge watching some
netflix
when you're bored on the tour bus what
are your go-to ways to pass the time
pass the time holy [ __ ]
that was that's insane the amount of
like where things just went
it's a big jump you don't spend much
time on the tour bus you just play the
show get on at like 11 p.m and sleep
and wake up in the city the next day are
you still the youtube guy that you were
a few
years ago what internet rabbit holes do
you find yourself going down 100
it's really bad like getting just
watching millions of these interviews
and laughing at people doing what i'm
doing right now
why did you feel let down when some of
your fans
said that you would belong to the
hufflepuff school at hogwarts
that's just messed up man you can't say
that to a harry potter fan
i know because hufflepuff is like i mean
they're smart right and they're creative
they're just like kind of mean nothing
sorry to all the harry potter fans who
are offended by that but
i care less about hufflepuff
am i dramatic right now no it's a lot
all right sean
you're eating some of the hottest
chicken wings on earth
there's no way it's it's
real it's real you've never seen me like
this before
i think i can't control anything
[Music]
did you ask me a question no we didn't
eat the wing yet
i'm i'm light-headed like really like
you're light-headed
i'm light-headed i lost all my hair i
have no feeling in my mouth
i don't know what the future holds it's
a lot it's a whole thing it's an
existential crisis sitting in this seat
we gotta finish it's giving me a bad
night
how much did you eat
so you've reached a level of notoriety
where you can't even go to the gym
without some meat head filming you on
the rowing machine and making a meme out
of it
yeah that was bad
why is leg day the most important day
it's in my throat the thing
um because it releases endorphins that
are supposed to just help all your
muscles grow
other than that it just sucks there's
nothing nicer about having big legs like
the strong legs like
and just like they suck what's your max
squat
yeah you won't believe me this is gonna
sound like i'm like i'm
boasting a lot but when i was 16 i
squatted 300 pounds
i had a i had a security guard what's up
john who was ex swat
he was like 300 pounds of muscle and he
got me like
if you look at pictures of me when i was
16 i was way too big my neck was like
exploding
[Music]
he got me squatting a lot a lot of
weight i squatted 300 pounds one day in
cleveland
and then i know that you're a really
nice guy but i wonder what's your gym
pet peeve
i hate when people are on like a squat
rack or a bench press and they're just
like
then you go to ask them how many sets
they have left and they reply to you
like they hate you
like why would you ask me that question
like we're all here to work out man
there's like two bench presses and
you're using one of them just tell me
how many sets i'm not trying to kill you
or not you know
or they're just like watching movies on
their phone at the bench press
all right sean mendes i feel so defeated
man
this is the last dab we call it the last
dab because it's tradition around here
to put a little extra on the last wing
you don't have to i'll do it can you do
if you don't want to of course i can i
don't think i can pick things up
i got you bro
you guys are messed up you just watch
people suffer for a living
there you go
the lights are so hot
you don't have to stand up for a second
i'm sorry take a lap take a lap it's all
good
it's all good i can't sit there for very
long in the beginning
sean you are very like this is chill
this is cool and then it accelerates on
you pretty quick
all right sean cheers man cheers my man
i'm shivering like i'm cold it's like
something's happening
i'm not going to breathe after this
you have a lot of people not do that one
all right shawn mendes
here we are at the hot ones finish line
and you just have one
more hurdle to jump i know there's a
third project
on the way you're not the doughy eyed
teenager that you were when you released
the first two so i have to know
what's something that you can finally
talk about on your third album that you
couldn't on the first two
uh drinking finally
not that i was drinking before i was
legal but
i let legal age in canada was 19 so it
was finally
okay to be able to talk about drinking
on the album
it's clear that you have a long career
ahead of you but in the singer
songwriter there always
is an evolution so i wonder when you
look into the crystal ball
and you look forward into your career
what's the album that you're looking
forward to most
the post controversy image
rehabilitation album
the he's not so innocent anymore check
out these migos features
album or the twilight of your career the
just you
and an acoustic guitar play in the hits
album i want the rehab rehabilitation
album
and i want the rehabilitation interview
a hot one's round
two okay sean master i'm gonna be very
vulgar you get that i promise
you heard it here first shake on it you
got it it's it's binding it is
officially binding and you're all
witnesses
but look at you sean mendes at the top
of the hot sauce mountain
taking out the wings cleaning them to
the bone and now there's nothing left to
do but roll out the red carpet
this camera this camera or this camera
let the people know what you have going
on in your life
well i have two songs out you guys can
go and listen
or download or buy in my blood and lost
in japan right now
the album's coming soon stay tuned i
love you guys thank you
[Music]
good job sharp good job jesus christ
holy [ __ ] look i'm gonna pass out
can i take this thing off yeah go ahead
do you get a thing where it's like your
body starts shaking
like a shiver hey what's going on hot
ones fans it's shawn evans and you know
what
i'm not going to beg for your
subscription if you're not subscribed
turn off the video it's over i want just
my subscribers
come here come here if you're subscribed
to first we feast
i just want to say thank you and then i
appreciate you
that i love you and i hope that you have
a great day